the session tomorrow on the board so you
know if you want to present your open
problem
add your name
all right so for the last uh session of
the morning we're really happy to have
uh sean kakade here and he's going to be
telling us about you know the
statistical complexity of reinforcement
learning right so you know if we want to
understand sample complexity in
multi-agent rl
where where do we have to start single
agent rl
so do you want to go ahead and take it
away sean
there you go
okay great
uh
thanks everyone for uh for joining and
thanks to simon's uh and the organizers
for
uh putting together this
forward-looking workshop and as dylan
pointed out this talk can be viewed as a
precursor to
the multi-agent problem
because
it's a precursor because
as we start moving to challenging
problems uh in ai
rl is becoming one of the the dominant
paradigms for
uh for interactive learning
and
uh there's a sense in which
the only setting that's more general
than
the rl problem is throwing strategic
agents into the mix
so
the focus of this talk is really going
to be going through understanding this
precursor problem of how we deal with uh
large high dimensional interactive
decision making
problems and trying to get at the
uh the statistical complexity of these
problems
so uh let's quickly remember our
challenge is reinforcement learning
we've got exploration the environment
may not be known we've got this credit
assignment problem in that we have to
take a sequence of decisions
to obtain some
rewards
and on top of all of that in challenging
problems we've got
a high dimensional state and action
spaces
okay so before
i go through the layout of the talk
let's just refresh our memory
for how we think about generalization
and quickly go through some uh basic
results in supervised learning and
reinforcement learning
okay so starting with supervised
learning
the bottom line in supervised learning
is we have a pretty good idea of how and
why we can generalize in supervised
learning and by that i mean
we can get reasonable
image recognition systems without seeing
every
possible image in the world
okay so in particular uh
we can do well in this agnostic learning
setting meaning that if we want to find
the best classifier in some hypothesis
class f or best regressor
uh and
you know to some epsilon additive
approximation the number of samples we
need scales only logarithmically with
the size of this class you know there
are many generalizations of this to
finite dimensions
margin based results neural networks
with bounded vc dimension and so on but
we have a number of complexity measures
that in various settings uh are
oftentimes even if and only if
statements for when we can
generalize
the key point supervised learning is we
can reuse data so with a training set we
can try out every classifier
on our training set to see how well it
does
let's look at
rl i'm going to use the standard
notation for reinforcement learning
so states or actions
are as rewards we have an underlying
process a markup process or
the agent takes an action observes the
state obtains the reward uh and uh
transitions to the next state
so uh our policy pi is a mapping from
states to actions uh we're gonna observe
a trajectory
uh once we execute our policy so think
of a trajectory as a sequence of state
action reward uh pairs over h steps so
we uh we'll execute a trajectory and
we'll so we'll execute a policy and
we'll observe a trajectory
and our notation is going to be the
standard one where we have a value
function of the policy at state s so
this is the future
uh expected value over h steps of
starting at state s and taking policy pi
and we have this an analogous sort of q
function this one step look ahead
function which is we start in s take a
executed for h steps
this will be our execute the policy pi
for h steps this would be our expected
reward
okay and our goal is to maximize a
policy from some say fixed starting
state or distribution over start states
and the key in the setting is
uh just like supervised learning we're
going to assume we don't know the world
so we have an unknown markov decision
process we're going to act for eight
steps and then we'll repeat so we've got
this episodic setting okay and what we'd
like to do is
you know minimize some notion of regret
or obtain good performance
okay
so
let's cover some uh basic results here
before we bump up a level and ask
ask a question
so
uh the most basic
uh setting here is let's just assume
uh the the problem is small like this
grid world kind of example and maybe
there's uh stochastic dynamics here okay
and you know we've got this beautiful
result uh going back to kerns and sig uh
showing that there is an algorithm with
with a polynomial number of samples uh
in the number of states actions and
horizon uh that can actually find in
your optimal policy and it can get low
regret
and this is non-trivial because to do
this you actually have to balance
exploration and exploitation and they
had this clever method of kind of
propagating uncertainty bonuses through
a dynamic program
okay and and even this is a non-trivial
unlike the supervised learning setting
okay so let's uh look at the other
extreme because the types of problems
we're interested
in rl are these big problems so we can
ask uh this question of what about uh
finding
uh say some policy or value function
that's best in class like the analog of
this agnostic supervised learning
problem so in particular we can ask this
question of can we find
say the epsilon best policy again with
no dependence on the number of states
just like an image recognition we want
no dependence on the number of images in
the world
so we'd like to have no s dependence say
polynomial horizon dependence and maybe
logarithmic dependence on
uh the the number of policies in the say
finite policy class this is like the
most
basic agnostic
reinforcement learning question okay and
it's not too difficult to convince
yourself that in fact this is not
possible
that
you know just uh
consider a binary tree
uh where you know you can move between
nodes there's one unknown rewarding leaf
node okay there are two to the eighth
possible policies and it's pretty clear
you're going to have to try uh
essentially all of them to find this
rewarding leaf node so you can't really
get below
either two to the h or log number of
policies
okay so this rules out this
sorry is that supposed to just be number
of policies
rather than log number of policies uh
yes that's the bug sorry yes thanks
dylan
um
yes let me fix that
yes
that should be a number of policies so
you you can't get uh
you can't really get um
uh log dependence
uh sorry no no uh that is uh
uh sorry it's the max of those two sorry
that's what i meant uh
so
uh
the but but the basic point is that uh
so i know it is it's the basic point is
you cannot get a logarithmic dependence
until you have a to the h samples
okay and the converse of that is once
you have
exponential h samples you can actually
get logarithmic dependencies
okay and the basic point here is unlike
supervised learning
we can't
you re-utilize the data very easily
because because of the interactive
nature of this problem uh we have to try
a policy to obtain data and it's not
obvious that this is going to be
informative of the performance of other
policies
okay so what i've tried to set up now is
two extremes okay so we've got this one
case when we where we have a tabular mdp
think of a tabular mdp is um you know i
call it tabular because just the number
of states and actions are small so when
we try solving this problem we can kind
of enumerate over the states we're
visiting so that one we can solve
efficiently in terms of in a statistical
sense
and we've got this other extreme that if
we just have some parametric policy
class and we'd like to find the best say
policy in that class or the the optimal
value function that class
that is not possible without having an
exponential dependence on the horizon
again what this talk is about is really
trying to understand
what lives in this region of where rl is
possible
in some statistical sense meaning a
model dependencies on
problem parameters of interest and and
what separates this region from what is
not possible okay and we're really going
to try to get some intuition uh about
what's going on here both in terms of
necessary and
uh sufficient conditions
okay so that's going to be that uh
what this talk is about and there's a
sense in which this talk is really going
to be surveying uh just tremendous
progress um from the community on on
these questions and i'll be going
through
uh how the community has
tried to address these problems uh some
of really the some of the breakthroughs
we've had
in trying to understand this
and
there's a sense in which we've made a
fair bit of recent progress on this as
well okay so we're going to start with
one of the most basic questions which is
can you do rl
with linearly realizable value functions
in a sense this question is trying to
give us a little understanding why rl is
is pretty subtle okay then we'll
jump into looking at sufficient
conditions and what's known in the
literature
in a sense this part is really going to
be a little intuition why it's
complicated
and and finally we'll um
look at some recent work on this new
idea of the decision decision estimation
coefficient and there's um you know
argue there's a real sense in which this
is the answer for
a very general complexity measure which
governs the learnability of
both rl and interactive decision
learning problems okay so i'm going to
jump in definitely feel free to
ask a couple clarifying questions along
the way
so again we're going to
keep this running picture as an example
and we're trying to understand
um
where things are statistically doable
um
we'll kind of get a sense what i mean by
that and and where in a sense
uh you can't do things um easily
statistically okay and the most basic uh
question to start with is that of
assuming we can approximate the optimal
value function with some linear features
right this is really just the analog of
questions about linear regression and uh
linear-based classification methods
okay and uh we think about you know
in a sense the simplest approach is we
we tend to um
we tend to utilize in machine learning
and statistics are linear ones so here
we could think about approximating our
state action value
uh
with
uh
with a function that is linear in some
known futures and and the idea here is
we want the dimensionality of this
function to be much much smaller than
the number of states and actions because
uh that that is what allows us to
avoid this cost of dimensionality and
not surprisingly this uh this idea is
very very old it's kind of implicit even
in some of shannon's work it's probably
older than that where even he was kind
of discussing
an idea of
uh kind of uh associate associate of
relations
uh with the reasonable features
okay and
there was this
kind of precise line of questions about
trying to understand
what properties do our features need to
satisfy uh in order for
these linear methods to uh to work in
reinforcement learning
okay and you know these questions are
really analogous to
uh what we do in say supervised problems
or say bandit problems when the horizon
is one like a linear bandit problem okay
so precisely uh sorry so here's um
one precise uh result which is
um
uh a bit surprising uh and i think this
really has a lot of deep implications
for
uh for how we think about rl and you
know to the extent that rl is relevant
for agents this has um deep implications
for the multi-agent setting as well okay
so the simplest assumption you can
possibly think of
uh with regards to linear maps is let's
just suppose q star lives in the span of
these features so for every state action
pair there exists some weights such as
this optimal
value function lives in the span of
these features
okay and uh
we can also make the problem easier by
making an assumption that the best
action has value
that's
you know non-trivially better than the
second best action right so in like the
in a multi-unbanded problem this is
known as a large gap assumption
uh and it basically says it's very easy
to identify the best action
okay so these are two assumptions where
we might hope uh to make that that will
make the problem easier to to solve
okay and
basically there's a series of results
addressing this problem okay and
in one of the stronger versions of it
it's this uh theorem here which says
assume we have an mdp which has this
linearly realizable value function and
you have a sub-optimal sub-optimality
gap okay and you're in this episodic
setting where you don't know the mdp you
just start run for eight steps and
repeat
okay and
the point here is that you need a number
of samples that's exponential either in
the dimension or the horizon to find
some policy that is additively close to
optimal
okay and this is like a slightly
stronger version of this result by weiss
at all and uh you know i would say
technically this result by wise this is
really a breakthrough result i mean many
people have been thinking about it and
this really has
deep implications because there's a real
sense in which the baby case in rl which
is linearly realized with value
functions we cannot solve this
statistically
okay and this result holds say without a
gap even in a jump with a general model
for those of you familiar with that and
these are pretty subtle uh proofs so the
proof here is actually relatively
concise but it is um
you know it takes a while to understand
what's going on here because there's a
lot of subtleties here
okay uh
and it turns out that the analogous
result for
uh linear realizable policies is also
not sufficient for sample efficient rr
meaning that if the policy
can be realized with a linear classifier
with a large margin
then you also can't do
rl
sample efficiently where you'll need
either exponentially derived the
dimension or horizon samples
okay and
in a nutshell
we're seeing a separation now between
the horizon one problem and the horizon
greater than one problem because the
horizon one problem the analogous
problems are you know banded
classification or regression which we
know we can do with a polynomial number
of samples okay but once the horizon
becomes larger than one
we start degrading exponentially
okay so
this is in in some ways um a bit
disappointing because it really is
suggesting we're going to need more
complicated
assumptions to get things to work
okay and and it is you know it's the the
most obvious thing we would try
is let's go back to our
a picture here
so we've got these tabular mdps which we
could do and disappointingly
uh you know what's again here we clearly
can't do things agnostically so we make
stronger assumptions but the most
natural stronger assumptions we make we
still can't do it
okay
so now we might start asking what are
uh sufficient conditions
uh for rl meaning can we get a sense of
what lives inside here
and note that this is a bit of a
subjective um
uh
um
line in that
i'm i'm calling like exponential
quantities in the
um
exponential problem dependent quantities
uh having those dependencies as being
are not being possible okay so
so if we have an exponential and d
quantity uh i'm going to place those
types of problems outside of this this
red boundary okay so let's try to get a
sense as to what are sufficient
conditions okay and i'm just going to
summarize some of the ways we've
the community has attacked this problem
and some of the progress that has been
made
the questions up to here
okay so
onto sufficiency
okay so
uh we know we can't do best in class
we know we can't do linear realizable q
star
but not surprisingly if we start making
stronger and stronger assumptions
there's lots of things we can do so
there's a whole lot there's a whole list
of
various assumptions where
we can do things well and we might be
asking you know what's the relationship
between these various
model classes and what permits sample
efficient learning
so let's just try to get a sense of
these various different models
and
generalizations and structural
characterizations of when things are
possible
this is a picture it turns out well we
know linear lqrs you can do sample
efficient rl in a sense they're even
simpler than
mdps because you don't really need to
explore
there's a very influential model by
some of the participants in this in this
workshop she who gave a talk uh this
morning
this linear mdp model
um
block mdp is another model where
it's a different set of assumptions
where you can do sample efficient rl
linear mixture models uh
these these two models there's a sense
in which they are pretty closely related
they both are kind of um
stronger linearity assumptions on the
dynamics that let you do efficient rl so
they're much stronger than linear q star
but on the other hand we know we need to
make stronger assumptions
some conditions on palm dps which lets
us do it efficiently in high dimensions
we can kind of kernelize this lqr
uh factored mdps
uh this pretty nice uh
setting where we can even think about a
notion of future learning where we can
uh do efficient rl
okay and you know the the question after
a while might be what are the
commonalities uh that are somehow
characterizing
uh the structure that is allowing us to
do this like is it just gonna look like
a big laundry list of
models where we can do rl efficiently
okay and there was this
uh really a breakthrough paper this
dominant rank paper uh and it was a
breakthrough conceptually in that i
think it really started understanding
the underlying structural conditions
which allowed us to do sample efficient
rl i'm not going to
go into too many of the details of this
paper but it really was the first paper
it was a bit overlooked at the time
but now people yeah like everyone knows
that they really have some very deep
insights here for
uh what's going on that actually allows
us to solve some of these problems
okay and
there's another related concept bellman
completeness
um
there's a model based version of this
dominant rank which captured some
additional cases
uh more recently there's a very nice
paper by again um
there's a wrong reference there
there's an earlier version but
she was one of the authors as well here
on this bellman eluder dimension it's
kind of generalizing this eluder
dimension concept
this is more about
understanding a term termination
condition
which
which governs when you can do things
and uh another um kind of a slightly
different way of viewing things from a
structural perspective which you could
view as generalizing
uh this bellman rank condition where
um
to i'll kind of you know highlight what
this condition is on the next slide
without going into too many details but
somehow the idea is there's a particular
low rank structure to these problems uh
which
you can generalize in this bilinear
class and in many cases it's worthwhile
just trying to use this condition to
verify if your problem satisfies it okay
and if it does you know there's an
efficient algorithm for it again what's
nice about this
these structure conditions is it becomes
very easy to find new models under which
you can do sample efficient rl
so like linear q star v star you can do
uh various other
conditions you can think about and you
can come up with models very easily by
seeing if they satisfy the structural
condition
okay feel free to let me know if my
slides aren't advancing sometimes i have
a problem we should be on bilinear
regret classes now
okay so
uh given the
um
the time so dylan i should stop around
uh 3 15.
uh yeah i mean we it's the lunch break
after this so it's probably okay if we
go a little over but yeah but i'll try
this stuff then so
uh
so
maybe i won't spend too much time
discussing the assumptions of the
bilinear classes but i'll give some of
the intuition behind what's going on
under the hood for this bellman rank
assumption and
uh the bilinear class assumption and the
basic idea is you're going to look at
your bellman error so the bellman era is
this one step look ahead error where you
know if you're optimal so suppose this
value function is greedy with respect to
q
okay and
the
so this is some kind of average bellman
error so q minus r minus v and
expectation should be zero if you've got
an optimal value function okay because
this v is uh the greedy value function
induced by this cube
okay and the idea now for
a lot of these approaches is the
structural condition somehow posits that
the average of this
uh dominant error somehow
uh lives in a low dimensional space
again what's interesting about this
assumption is you don't
necessarily need to know the features of
this
of this uh average dominar but if you
have this a type of property like this
where this average bellman era is small
under
various other roland policies
then somehow the idea is this allows you
to try to generalize and reutilize data
because you can try to enforce this
average bellman error to be zero under
other policies right somehow the key for
supervised learning is we have a way to
reutilize data and the idea for these
approaches is the sum assumption which
allows us to try to you know enforce
this development error is zero by
reutilizing past data okay so i'll let
people look at the details
of these papers but uh it's a much
stronger assumption that um
that we need to impose to get things uh
uh to work
uh and
if you have it
you're good
okay but it's subtle
so let's uh bump up a level now and uh
go back to
our picture here
and
it'd be nice if somehow this was the
full story but
uh it kind of isn't because we do
realize that
uh almost certainly
the the rl problems in practice we want
to solve once we start mixing in say
deep learning approaches and so on
they're going to have to go beyond i
think both these alluder and bilinear
types of approaches
and on top of that
we kind of believe
you know we don't really know what the
boundary is out here
and so in particular
there may be natural things
um
that that actually do live out here
uh and particularly this is irrelevant
when we start thinking about uh even
more nonlinear types of approaches
uh and
uh we'd also like to
potentially get better insights for
algorithms that will work under various
assumptions
okay and we know this is partly the case
because
there's a deterministic linear q star
assumption so you know linear q star
doesn't work but if the dynamics in
other words are deterministic then you
can in fact solve this problem and that
lives outside of
of of what we know
so
now let's uh think a little more broadly
and ask other necessary and sufficient
conditions like can we really pin down
uh the the line in the sand which
separates what's learnable in in some
polynomial sense and what is it
okay and uh you know this is a very
general question it's like can we really
pin down
uh
what actually governs the learnability
of uh interactive learning problems
under different modeling assumptions
okay this is part three and this is
going to be some uh pretty recent work
okay so so let's bump up a level and
consider and a more abstract setting uh
which is this decision making with
structured observations yeah there's a
sense in which uh this is basically just
an rl setting but i think phrasing it
this way
lets us think a little more abstractly
okay so
uh so this dmso setting is a setting
where
uh we have a decision set pie so this is
the set of feasible decisions they could
be in bandits they could be arms
uh in rl it's going to be policies
uh and in this abstract setting i'll
ground it in a moment
we have a distribution uh over a reward
you know it's gonna be an episodic
setting we have a distribution over
reward r and observations o for every
policy so if we place some some decision
pi then the world specifies a
distribution of the reward we obtain
and the observations we see and the
observations could be
just something in an abstract space
okay and the game is as follows so for
every time step
the learner is going to place some pi t
you know it could be a policy it could
be an arm well nature's going to reveal
some reward rt this is capital r to
distinguish it from little r and rl and
we're going to observe some observation
ot sample it from this underlying
distribution we just repeat this for a
while
okay so uh just to be concrete the way
our all fits in this framework is
these pies are policies uh what we're
going to do is that every episode we're
going to
place some policy the total reward in
this episode this big rt is going to be
the sum over the little rewards we see
over the h steps and the observation we
obtain is just the trajectory of what we
observed over the h steps this is really
a very abstract setting this dmso set
these are just questions about the
setting right now
so don't you know so think of big r as
just the the reward in the episode so
it's really the sum of the little r's
and rl and o is any kind of abstract
structured observation space
we good
okay so so what's our
abstract goal here
right because
you know obviously i could have like
said dmso is like a setting of rl2 or
vice versa but it's nicer to kind of
abstract it away say we have the scalar
reward which is you know rl the sum of
the literal words and some very
structured observation space which is
how nature gives us information
okay and
what we're going to ask is really a
decision theoretic analog of these
classical optimal statistical estimation
questions okay and uh
that question is as follows so let's
just suppose we have a set of models
okay and think of a model as something
for which
um
it's something for which for every uh m
in your model class that's going to
specify a distribution over the reward
and observations for any policy right so
an mdp is a model because for every
policy you have a distribution over
trajectories and rewards okay so for
example one one example of a model class
is the set of all tabular mdps okay and
you can even do
a model three approaches here because
you know just let this model class
script m just to be the set of all mdps
whose optimal value functions are
consistent with being linear in this
given future mapping phi
okay so this is very abstract you know
we call it models but it's very easy to
make it
value based or policy based just through
uh
through assumptions like this okay now
let's go
go ahead and make this realizability
assumption where we're going to say
there is some
model where the truth is in the smaller
class isn't kind of hand-waving notation
by dropping the subscript because for
every model it's associated with this
family of distributions but let's
suppose there is a model such that the
truth is in the model class meaning that
for every policy pi and pi that's going
to be specified by uh you know the
distribution r and o is going to be
specified by some uh big m
okay and what's our
uh
uh
our regret question here our optimal
statistical estimation question here
okay so let's say the value function is
just the expected reward
uh
when we play decision pi this is just
like rl so in model m
v pi of m is just the expected uh you
know the reward in that episode given
that we play pi
and our abstract optimal estimation
question here this min max question is
what's the best we can do for an
arbitrary model class script m
uh when we know the truth lies in this
class so this is a min over all learning
algorithms
uh you know the nature is going to
make things as uh worst case as possible
and we're gonna measure ourselves by our
regret when we don't know the the
underlying bottle so this is the best we
could have done in the truth versus the
performance of our our uh online
decision making algorithm which you know
observes the
uh it uh sees the observation and and it
can update the decisions it takes at the
next episode because the questions about
the setting
this is very general it basically will
capture all of the different settings we
had before and we'd like to understand
is there a way to start thinking about
uh the rate
uh we can obtain here based on
properties of the underlying model class
and various other regular conditions
okay so let's start getting some
intuition uh here and and
intuition for why this is a very subtle
um
this is a very subtle
set of questions so uh let's try to
understand when problems are easy or
hard and let's do this uh with with uh
uh with a zeroth order optimization
problem so there's some true model m
and the setting is uh our decisions now
are some real number and what we're
going to observe is
uh an underlying function corrupted with
noise so in pictures suppose we know the
truth is one of these three functions
we're going to play a decision which is
a real number and what we observe is the
function value corrupted by noise and
we'd like to do well over
uh playing this game many times okay um
but suppose this is our game is this
problem easy or hard
well suppose i told you the true
function lies in this class and you know
we want to maximize the reward
it turns out this is a very
uh easy problem why
well
you know just choose the decision here
because
this decision is simultaneously optimal
for all the models uh in this class so
you know even though
the optimal algorithm here we're not
going to discover the correct model this
is a very easy interactive decision
making problem because
uh of this um you know the the because
of the particular properties of this
model found
because this one's easy
okay this one's a bit harder
why because uh we actually do need to do
some type of exploration
uh to try to figure out where the
optimal decision is right if we do
something here it's bad for this blue
guy if we do something here it's bad for
the the red one and we're going to have
to bounce around
some amount of time before we can
narrow things down enough to start doing
well
this is a bit harder
but let's tweak this to see why
uh this framework uh things can be very
subtle here
okay so now let's change the functions
again remember we're playing uh
decisions that are real numbers we'd
like to maximize the reward and we keep
queering things and we get
uh corrupted feedback we get the
function plus a little noise okay but
now we've kind of bent this function
down here and we've kind of created some
nice big gaps here so you know think of
this as a nice separation here okay so
now is this problem easy or hard
um
it's basically easy but what's
interesting about this one you know
you've got this kind of cheating action
which will reveal the model okay so what
you should do for this problem if you're
playing again if you're playing it for a
very long time you should really just
play this guy a few times to figure out
which model it is and then just jump to
the right answer
okay and
note that this framework
um is captured in this dmos type of
setting because we you know our model
class is this
okay so this is pretty subtle because if
we're going to try to characterize this
uh you know
this min max rate
uh there's all kinds of strange cases we
could um
we'd have to deal with for example you
know maybe
your
your model class is such that uh you
know the low order bits in the gaussian
noise technically aren't noise they
might actually encode something about
the right answer right instead of adding
epsilon noise in the bits like 10 to the
minus 10 and lower they they in some you
know they have some bit encoding which
reveals the right answer
that might be a corner case
uh but what's subtle is that um
and you know you could maybe argue that
this example i showed you now like maybe
this is just very unnatural but once you
start thinking about rl and what's going
on it's not obvious what
separates these
weird corner cases because linear q star
isn't doable and the cases that are
doable are these you know
eluder dimension
assumptions bilinear class bellman rank
assumptions uh and
you know we don't really have a good
sense as to
what's this uh
this separation
uh so
uh so instead you know when we're
working on this is
the question is can we really just try
to generally get it get a handle on
what's going on for arbitrary classes m
but i think i can issue this is very
subtle because
there are all kinds of weird things that
you can exploit in an arbitrary model
family to improve to improve the rate of
regret
okay so
going back to our picture here now
okay and this is really going to be a
punch line is there's a real sense in
which
this this new concept the decision
estimation coefficient really does
establish
uh this line in this end between what is
uh learnable and what isn't in this very
general interactive learning setting
okay and in a precise sense um okay so
you should really view this this red
line precisely as lower bounds meaning
that everything outside of this red line
you cannot do and everything inside you
can and and this accurate affects this
picture so i'll be a little more precise
in a moment but
um you know basically this dec concept
captures the learnability of all known
models
and
there are some subtleties but there's
reason to believe that
with regards to sufficiency any time
it's bounded
we do believe that in fact there is an
algorithm uh you know but we need some
stronger assumptions to get sufficiency
but certainly
uh from a lower bond perspective it does
look like this uh dec
is nailing the line and ascend between
what is learnable and what isn't
okay so let's see what this complexity
measure is
i'll just try to state what it is and
give a little intuition about it in the
remaining remaining few minutes
okay so
uh it's gonna you know we'll start by
defining uh defining with respect to
some reference model in our model family
okay this gamma is going to be a scale
think of this scale as
uh being like root key which is the
number of episodes you're gonna you're
gonna play but think of this as an
arbitrary scale now trading off regret
and uh information
okay so the idea of having this
reference model is going to be that
uh we believe the
you know so suppose we believe uh the
model is close to the reference model in
some kl sense okay so that's what this
lagrangian is doing
okay and what this co what this
coefficient is you can think about this
as a game between
uh the
the learner and
uh nature
okay so the learner is going to pick a
distribution over a decision so this is
going to be just a distribution of a
policies the nature is going to pick a
model
okay and then we're going to look at
this expected quantity the first term is
just the regret so this is just uh how
much you know this is our sub optimality
in expectation for the model that
nature has chosen
okay so that's just the usual regret
okay but the second term is uh
interesting because
uh we're getting
um a discount we're getting an
improvement uh if it turns out that for
the decision we played
what we're observing
is far from the reference model
why is that helpful because that's
giving us information that in fact uh
the model is incorrect like it'd be very
bad somehow if what we played was uh
uh had regret and somehow it wasn't
giving us any information that
distinguishes it from this reference
model again gamma kind of trades these
two off and this is sort of why this
name is the the decision uh estimation
coefficient so technically the the paper
uses uh the the hellinger distance but
allenger this is this doesn't really
matter it's just for some technical
technical reasons
okay and then when we define the dec
we're just going to take
a max over these reference models
okay but
it's an interesting notion and certainly
you know it has some relations between
prior quantities
if we think about reversing the order of
this max and min it also makes some
interesting connections to
bayesian approaches
let's see
i would have a time for like one
clarifying question if someone just
isn't clear what the definition is i
mean it takes a little while to think
things through but i think
you know i tried to give you some of the
intuition here
about the concept
he said so up to here i've only defined
a concept i'll tell you what it's good
for in the next slide
i do want to mention what's interesting
about this concept is
this concept really does seem to be the
right generalization of
a decision you know of of a quantity
that's characterized as the min max
complexity in
uh basically supervised learning
problems uh so this is really a line of
work going back to the com on optimal
cystical estimation and this seems to
generalize like a certain modulus of
continuity notion
okay so
um so now so now what is this uh this
notion good for
okay so
uh so again remember this is a general
setting where m could be essentially
anything that you could take mdb the set
of uh you know
linear mdps with some given feature
mapping or be model free
the set of mdps whose
linear whose value functions are
consistent with some q star
okay
so now let's look at the upper and lower
bounds here okay so
the lower bound is a really really nice
here because it's very very general
it's just some really minor regularity
conditions
and what we have is that
the regret for any algorithm is lower
bounded by
we take a max over these scales
and we're really just trading off the
this coefficient at scale gamma times t
versus gamma so you know i think of
gamma as like uh one over root t this
often recovers uh results in many
settings but but this lower bound
basically is a very very general lower
bound it turns out for upper bounds we
have to make further convexity
assumptions and then we can obtain upper
bounds in terms of
some way to get at a supervised learning
era
okay so i'll let people look at the the
details and that's why in a sense this
doesn't entirely close uh things and you
you know you you wouldn't expect to
grab quite everything but in terms of a
lower bound sense uh there's not much we
don't have any reason to believe this
doesn't this lower bond doesn't capture
just about everything i mean certainly
it's a valid lower bound but uh we do
believe that
uh whenever you know that that it's
achievable in in all reasonable cases
okay and in particular
you know for uh
for the sort of convex m
uh that we get sub linear regret if and
only if this um
this decision estimation coefficient
decays
with respect to gamma at some
polynomial rate
and then we'll get sublinear regret
okay and to support this uh this point
why this uh this assumption really nails
things down
is
you know just end okay so before i get
to that uh i do think it's worth
emphasize that
uh this framework really is uh
generalizing this um you know very
important and elegant classical theory
of optimal statistical estimation due to
a com and it's really bringing this to
the interactive learning setting in a
very general sense and this is a much
more challenging setting because you
know the game is you're not just going
to do mles for this setting you actually
have to interact with the world to
uh to be optimal
okay so before ending
let me uh
i do not have the table
okay so um
uh okay let me just end so
um
i had a table basically showing that uh
all of the
the known
cases you could do with interactive
learning
let me uh see if i can find it
is that so uh before ending i'll just
point out that
essentially all
uh
interactive learning frameworks this dec
lower bound is basically tight in
uh up to poly factors and sometimes you
know in most of these cases it actually
nails the poly factors in the
problem-dependent quantities of interest
now you do have to do a fair bit of work
to establish these rates but it's a bit
surprising that there is one quantity
which characterizes the rate
okay so finally let me just wrap things
up
the main point here is that
we're getting a theory of how to handle
rl in these high dimensional problems
which is clearly irrelevant if we start
moving to more challenging multi-agent
problems
we got some intuition that linear
realizability we couldn't do things with
there's a framework
for
getting sufficiency there's a couple of
different frameworks that are natural
and more recently there's this quantity
that does seem to characterize when
learnability is possible and finally i
just highlight some of the
the terrific colleagues that were
involved in this line of work
and you know look you know more
generally this is really a line of work
from the community but a couple of
people i should highlight like rusong
and yonha
on these lower bonds grav mahogan and
simon do for
uh for some of this work on bilinear
classes and uh you know dylan and gian
so dylan's one of the organizers here
and he's really been just driving this
work on the dec and really trying to
understand these fundamental limits of
um
of interactive learning and you know
he's around for the week so definitely
ping ping his brain on the
dec stuff so thank you very much and
happy to take a few questions
well thanks a lot
[Applause]
yeah we can take some questions before
we head off to lunch
hi um in your definition of dec um you
said that essentially you build a
lagrangian does your definition also
directly extend if you consider instead
like um a distance in terms of epsilon
you had like a coupled min max problem
there instead
when you say coupler do you mean
constrained or do you mean like a
constrained coupled optimization problem
where you're also looking for the
optimal gamma there
in some sense like you you pick an
epsilon so you pick the epsilon that
defines the kl divergence
between the two things and instead
you're looking for the optimal like
lagrange multiplier the kkt multiplier
associated
with that epsilon
uh so in a sense okay so there's a
there's definitely a couple of uh a few
subtleties going on here so
uh in in the way this proof works and in
you know the the lower bound okay let me
comment on two things and maybe dylan
can add a bit more so with regards to
the lower bound uh we're optimizing over
uh this gamma so that is coupled and
it's actually important to trade it off
with a gamma here because
in a sense like if you think about
multi-arm bandits there's this trade-off
between
um
you know if you kind of don't discover
the right thing what do you get
okay so so from a lower bond perspective
it's explicitly in the statement because
you are optimizing over the gamma
now for the upper bound perspective
things are more interesting because
you would like to use this for deriving
the framework but you know
this you know you could view this as
just some some types of unknown you you
know you one would have to i think have
problem dependent information to
understand how to set gamma with regards
to uh upper bound algorithms and you
know one can see that in multi-unbanded
frameworks and i think one implicitly
sees that in
uh like the square cd work that dylan
has done maybe dylan can you can add a
couple of comments
i mean i can just briefly say like
yeah so the conditions you would like to
use to relate this to kind of a
constrained version they don't exactly
go through due to various like
properties of the setting you can kind
of do lower bounds in terms of like a
constrained version of this quantity but
yeah the upper bounds not obvious right
but the other half of the question was
about uh
um
if you could actually set the value of
gamma like in the program somehow oh
yeah um
yeah there's a sense in which you really
shouldn't be able to do that in like a
data dependent fashion yeah that's the
that's the point right like you kind of
need some problem dependent quantities
together i mean for the lower bond there
is a sense in which it is set because we
just have a max over all the scales
um for sure
let's see are there any other questions
oh high point yep
so i have a quick question about the
model so there are problems where within
each episode the learner can update the
policy based on the feedback on the fry
so can your model capture this kind of
problems
uh yeah i mean uh because um
uh
so i mean the dm the okay so abstractly
the answer is yes the dmso does but in
terms of the way the lower bounds work
they aren't really
getting at um
uh
you know like
think of it this way if i told you h was
like super super long and you only had
one episode uh and if you mixed then you
could solve uh you know you could do rl
like the lifelong learning kind of
setting the lifelong learning setting t
is one okay so it can't it sort of can't
capture that so there is a sense in
which the the dms or framework allows
you to do that but the lower bounds do
not really say anything
uh meaningful
uh when h starts becoming you know if
you think about the rl setting where it
starts becoming very very large
uh it's um
yeah it doesn't really capture
uh
that regime
but you know conceptually all of the
cases we know how to handle these things
we
often mix or reset or um
that there's some implicit way of
restarting the system uh
through mixing or resetting
to address this and it's plausible some
of the techniques can
uh be extended to this but it's much
easier to
do the analysis with the separation of
making things episodic and try to pin
that one down first
is that uh
are there any other questions for now
all right uh oh i'll just check the chat
no no no questions in chat um yeah so i
guess if that's it i guess we can stop
there and uh you know go for lunch uh
but yeah let's thank sean again it was a
great talk